- I wasn't highly recruited.
I wanted to go to Maryland.
And the Maryland coach
was like, "Ah, you
gotta work on your jump shot."
- I started playing
in fourth grade.
I, too, was not good.
I was tripping over
lines on the floor.
- [Laughing]
- What have you thought
about finances?
- One of our owners, they
own the stock exchange!
So it's like, why am I
not talking about stocks
and what I can get into?
- It would never occur to
me to do that, because, you know,
you come into the league at 22.
I'm like, "I'm gonna
buy an apartment complex?"
- [Laughing]
- This is "The Reunion," where
former college athletes meet up
to discuss lessons learned
about sports, money and life.
I'm Taylor Rooks, here
with Angel McCoughtry
and Napheesa Collier.
Well, you know, before we really
dive into things,
I want us to zoom out a bit.
You know, so much time has passed. You know,
you guys being in the WNBA,
time in college.
When you look at this
moment right now,
did you envision your life
being what it is right now?
- I didn't.
Even growing up, playing
with all the boys,
they're like, "Hey, you can play
in this thing called the WNBA
one day."
And I'm like, "What's that?"
You know?
And then I started to envision
playing in the WNBA.
But I never envisioned going
to different countries,
learning different
languages, being an Olympian,
getting a gold medal, right?
So those are experiences
that you just—I mean, people dream of, you know?
- Mmhmm.
- So it's been an amazing ride.
- I think it was
the dream, but you
don't know what to envision
so you see the big
milestones. Like, I wanna
go to the Olympics someday.
- Right.
- I wanna play in
the WNBA someday.
But it's like the day-to-day—like,
this kind of stuff
or, like, playing overseas—that you
really don't think about.
I didn't, at least, in high
school and college, really.
- I mean, it's so cool
to think, you know, just how
beautiful it is
that basketball now
has given you so many things.
And the work that you
put into basketball
has given you so many things.
So I wanna know when you knew
you were better than everyone
else?
- [Laughing]
- When did y'all
know you were good?
- You know what?
OK, so I started at eight
years old. Always played,
just loved it.
And I was, like, the last
one coming off the bench.
I was not that player.
People would think
that from our success,
but I wasn't that player.
I feel like during
my career, I've
always had to be the type
to prove people wrong.
I wasn't highly recruited.
I wanted to go to Maryland,
and the Maryland coach
was like, "Ah,
you gotta work
on your jump shot."
So I've always had to
overcome these obstacles.
And even at Louisville, them
not going past the first round
of the tournament.
But by my senior year, we're in
the national championship game,
playing UConn, being ranked.
So I've always had to overcome.
To be a part of a
legacy with Louisville,
it's really, really good to see that.
Cuz now, more girls are
going to different schools
and creating their own legacies.
- Mmhmm.
- Yeah, I started playing
in fourth grade.
- Mmhmm.
- So kinda around the same time.
I, too, was not good.
I was super tall, lanky.
I've always been, like, tripping
over lines on the floor.
- [Laughing]
- Not graceful at all.
I think I started noticing that
I was getting better probably
around, like, sixth grade,
seventh grade, and then
eighth grade for sure.
You kinda see the
separation a little bit there.
- [Angel:] Start to see it, yeah.
- [Taylor:] I think we should take a
lil' trip down memory lane.
- [Angel:] Yes.
- I know how crazy, how loud
it would get in Storrs.
How would you just describe
that fanbase at UConn?
- You know, our gym was a
little bit smaller,
so it only fit 10,000 people.
So it felt so loud.
But our fans are so cool.
And like I said, some of my
best memories are from there,
and a lot of it had to do
with the games and the fans.
- So, when you all
make it to the WNBA
and you're having these
conversations about money,
making decisions,
who did you go to?
- I'm still learning, I feel like.
Because—you know what it is? Even though,
like you said,
our paychecks aren't a
lot, it's still more money
than I've ever seen.
So it feels like you
have, like, so much money
when you first start out.
- Yeah.
- So relying on people
like my agent,
my parents, you know, the older
people on my team
who have been through this.
- I think you make a few
mistakes before you realize,
"OK, this is the
route I need to go."
I think any successful
businessperson
will tell you that they've
made so many mistakes before.
And it's nothing
to be ashamed of.
It's a learning experience.
You know, you wanna be able
to call up people
you know for different things.
So even to encourage all the
players, talk to your owners.
Your owners are big-time
successful businesspeople.
Ask them their story.
Talk to them about
what they're doing.
I didn't know that
in the beginning.
- Yeah.
- You know?
So that's just a little word of
advice for everyone out there.
- For someone watching who
maybe doesn't understand
WNBA players going
overseas, can you
explain that process for them?
- Yes.
It is a long grind.
You're talking about eight
months in another country.
Great thing is your family
becomes your teammates.
It is very tough.
You have to be mentally tough.
- My first year was 2020.
I was going to play in China.
I was there for 10 days.
And then coronavirus hit there
first, so I had to come home.
I took, like, a half-year
playing in France, like,
going into the WNBA season
so that my body would be ready
and things like that,
but I could also enjoy my time.
- But that's still a sacrifice.
- Yeah.
- Just the fact that you go over
there, that's a sacrifice.
- Yeah!
Yeah, absolutely.
- [Angel:] Yes!
- Yeah, and you're just thinking,
"OK, well, when can I see them?"
But then in the back of
your head, you're also like,
"I'm doing this for them as well."
- You know, before she retires, I want them
to have their first million-dollar
contracts.
They deserve it, and I feel
like it is coming soon.
I would not be mad about that.
- [Laughing]
- [Napheesa:] I retweet that.
- [Taylor:] So what has, or how has your definition
of a good teammate
evolved as you've gotten older?
- Having good communication, being
supportive, being encouraging
and being a little
bit vulnerable.
Your teammates wanna
see you be vulnerable.
I think as I've
gotten more vulnerable,
I've gotten close
with my teammates.
- Something I do always
wanna frame—
and I want you all's
take on this—
I think too often when
we're talking to girls,
young women, we frame being a
woman, like, as an obstacle, something
you're having to
overcome all the time.
And I don't think that that's
the right way to frame it.
I know we all gain a lot of
strength, you know, from being women.
In what ways, you know, has just
your experience as a woman
made you a stronger,
better person?
- You have to be stern.
You have to be confident.
You have to know what you want,
so your no's aren't negotiated.
- Yeah, "no" is a complete sentence.
That's what I'm always told.
"No" is a complete sentence.
What about for you?
- I think because people
see it as an obstacle,
it makes us tougher.
Being a woman is
so, so powerful.
And we have, like, this inner
strength because even
if people are doubting us,
we know that we can do it.
- [Angel:] Exactly.
- Yeah, absolutely.
So, as you look forward
to the next 10 years,
what do you wanna accomplish?
- I probably wanna be in
the position that you're in,
probably the exact
same one, you know?
Getting ready to wind down my career
and financially stable.
And, like, you're so
knowledgeable about it.
I feel like there's so
much I still need to learn.
So I wanna be in a position
where I know what I'm doing,
I can go confidently
into new investments,
know how to research
them, things like that.
So really just kind of learning
all the stuff that I don't even
know I don't know.
- Yeah.
- Awesome, yeah.
- Next 10 years for you.
- I wanna be a
great businesswoman.
I wanna be able to
also help the younger
generation, the younger
girls in the league.
And I wanna be able to
help the young girls who
are kinda green to not knowing, you know?
Cuz I, we didn't know, you know?
- Yeah.
- And be just a great businesswoman.
I would love to be like the
LeBron James of, you know, the WNBA.
With everything
he's doing, I just
wanna have my
hands in everything.
- Yeah, absolutely.
Well, I am so inspired
by both of you.
I'm so happy to be sitting
here with you guys.
- Thank you so much.